>>Paul Snow: Perfect.
Excellent, well thanks everybody for joining
us tonight.
My name’s Paul Snow, I’m part of the team
at YouTube here in Los Angeles.
[Cheering]
>>Audience Member: Woo, Paul!
Paul!
>>Paul Snow: And goodnight!
We’re good!
[Laughter]
>>Paul Snow: We have some gentlemen up here,
as well, that deserve much more clapping than
I do.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: I don’t want the clap.
>>Paul Snow: Alright, so you can do the Arsenio
Whoop instead, so make sure you do that.
[Laughter]
>>Paul Snow: Let me go down the line.
Andre Royo is here visiting us as well as
David Oyelowo, we also have Eli Kelley, we
have a guy named Rick McCallum as well.
And we’ve just had the opportunity--
[Applause]
>>Paul Snow: So welcome to Los Angeles, welcome
to Google Los Angeles and we’ve just had
the opportunity to screen Red Tails, amazing
movie.
We have a few questions that we’re gonna
start out with about the movie and about your
experience making it.
But then we have an audience here that’s
anxious to ask you questions as well.
So, you guys ready?
>>All: Yeah.
>>Paul Snow: So first off, for those that
haven’t seen the movie yet, it’s about
Tuskegee Airmen, we’d love to hear a little
bit about your guys' experience and how you
first heard about the Tuskegee Airmen.
>>David Oyelowo: Well for me, personally,
my first encounter, uh, of the Tuskegee Airmen
was reading the script for Red Tails.
And, uh, you know that in and of itself is
something I’m ashamed to say considering
how incredible these guys were and what they
did.
But at least I have the excuse of being British.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: But when I,
>>Elijah Kelley: but you’re still black.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: He just said but I’m still
black.
>>Andre Royo: It’s true.
It’s true.
>>David Oyelowo: Can you believe?
You’re right, I am still black.
I am still ashamed.
Thank you.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: But, you know when I read
the script and when I started doing research
around the subject matter, what I was shocked
to find is that a lot of Americans, both white
and black, didn’t know either.
And that’s when it became a real, kind of,
obsession of mine to be both part of telling
the story and to educate people about who
they were.
>>Rick McCallum: For you.
>>Elijah Kelley: Thanks.
I grew up in a very, very small town called
Lagrange Georgia, which is about 45 miles
Southeast of Tuskegee.
So there is very rich heritage there.
A lot of the airmen have said that they used
to fly over where I grew up and as we were,
you know, maturing as children, these stories
of their bravery would always be told to us
as inspiration.
So it was very near and dear to me already.
>>Rick McCallum: I first heard, I never heard
of the Tuskegee Airmen until 1989 and George,
a very good friend of George Lucas’ had
told him the story and, uh, he loved, he loved
battles, he loved air sequences, he had used
them in Star Wars, the original Star wars,
and he was, the minute he heard the story,
the minute he told it to me, this was '89
for me and he had started about a year before.
It was such a no-brainer because it was just
such a fantastic story about, you know, people
overcoming the most extraordinary odds, but
also an action adventure story, it had a lot
of history.
And one of the biggest problems that took
us so long, um,
[Audience member coughing]
>>Rick McCallum: for him to actually come
up with a way to make it is it was so big
cause there was the Tuskegee part, which was
an extraordinary story of unbelievable racism,
a tragic part of American history.
Then there’s the great part of the guys
finally getting the shot, the chance that
they always yearned for.
And there’s also, of course, when they came
back they were treated like absolute, can
we swear?
[Laughter]
>>Paul Snow: Sure, go for it.
>>Rick McCallum: Treated like absolute
>>Elijah Kelley: There’s kids here.
Kids everywhere.
>>Rick McCallum: Oh, sorry.
>>Andre Royo: All the kids right there.
>>David Oyelowo: Treated very badly, very
badly.
>>Rick McCallum: So there’s these three
big, big stories so, um, but it was like,
“Oh my God, this is just such a fantastic
idea, this is such a fantastic story,” I
never thought we’d go through the pain to
try get it made for so long, but finally it
was worth it for us.
>>Paul Snow: Excellent.
So you guys have been out talking to the public
about the movie.
What’s been you’re experience around their
awareness of the Tuskegee Airmen.
>>David Oyelowo: Well, I mean, sorry Rick.
I mean, now having seen the movie, some of
it is anger, some of it is sadness that it’s,
“Why, now, do we know about this?”
Especially for young black people that you
know, we got a letter the other day from a
school that had attended a screening and they
were angry that it wasn’t part of the curriculum
and that it was kind of a footnote in terms
of the things that they get to learn.
At the end of the day, what we do with Red
Tails that I’m so happy about is we celebrate
them as heroes.
We don’t, you know, the film isn’t about
the brow-beaten black man, which is so much
of what you can see in these kinds of movies
in a sense, often that’s what’s portrayed.
But these guys, one of the privileges for
us was getting to be with Roscoe Brown, getting
to be with Lee Archer, getting to be with
Bill Holloman, some of the airmen who were
exemplary as Tuskegee airmen during the Second
World War.
You know, they never let the prejudice, they
never let the obstacles that they faced, be
the thing that stopped them from doing what
they wanted to do, which was to both save
the world from, you know, a dictatorship,
and show themselves worthy of respect back
home and show themselves to be patriotic Americans,
and they did not let the prejudice stop them.
So, you know, this is something that as people
are getting to see that in the film, that
there’s a combination of celebration, anger
and sadness that it had taken this long for
them to be celebrated in this way.
>>Paul Snow: That’s great.
In watching the movie there was a pretty amazing
bond between the cast.
I heard some rumors about a boot camp, or
something else that was done that maybe helped
forge some of those bonds before the filming
started.
[Laughter]
>>Rick McCallum: That was the best part for
me watching.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: I still want to choke you
for that
[Laughter]
>>Paul Snow: For those that had to go through
it and those that watched others go through
it, you wanna tell us a little bit about what
you did?
>>Elijah Kelley: I personally went through
boot camp and before meeting George Lucas
and Rick, I hated them
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: Because they put us through
this.
When I tell you –. It was a tremendous mental
struggle, physical struggle, spiritual struggle
cause we wanted to kill everybody that we
saw, and the worst part about it was where
it was set up, it was set up in an abandoned
warehouse, uh, in the winter of Prague, the
Czech Republic, so there’s snow everywhere.
This warehouse has no heat, nothing is modern
about this and it was how many square feet
was it?
It was probably about--
>>Rick McCallum: It was probably about 4 to
5,000 square feet but there were also no windows.
>>Elijah Kelley: No, no, the warehouse was
about 4 to 5,000 square foot; the place we
slept in was a closet.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: It was 8 people, the beds,
the beds were, um, there was about a foot's
length between each bed, we woke up; our alarm
clock was M80’s shot gun rifle simulations.
We had just impromptu 9 mile hikes in the
middle of the night.
People fell out, people cried.
>>David Oyelowo: Elijah cried.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: No I didn’t cry, there
was a lot of precipitation.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: in the Czech Republic at
that time of the year, David.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: He cried.
>>Elijah Kelley: But it was one of those experiences
that it was genius because they set it up
where as the Tuskegee airmen had the same
situation, they only had each other.
So there was a bonding experience that you
knew when those bombs went off, that the person
right next to you was gonna have your back
regardless of what went down.
And that was kind of the trajectory of how
the bond got started, because we knew, you
know listen, they set us up literally in 1940,
the music was period, the food was period,
the way we had to interact with, there was
no social media, no cell phones, no anything
for over a week.
And that bond, it just set us up for not only
being brothers for the duration of the movie,
but for a lifetime, in my opinion.
>>David Oyelowo: And also we were very aware
that we were being afforded a completely unique
opportunity.
I defy you to find a movie of this scale with
a, you know, almost entirely African American
cast where we are the center of the story.
You know, it’s not told through a white
person’s perspective, or a white character.
Like Glory did or like, you know, The Help
did, or the Last King of Scotland did, or
Blood Diamond did, you know, the way Hollywood
tells black stories is to do it through the
prism of a white perspective.
And so we were, you know, this is the genius
of George and why we are eternally indebted
to George, is that like he did with American
Graffiti took a bunch of unknowns and just
went and did it anyway, like with, you know,
Star Wars when no one was making Sci-fi at
that time, and he did it anyway.
He did that with us, you know, no one was
gonna make this movie with a bunch of no name
actors so to speak, I mean, Cuba and Terrence
are a different matter.
But largely the film centers around these
pilots.
So we were very, very cognizant of the privilege
of getting to do this.
So that was very bonding as well.
>>Andre Royo: It is cool.
It was cool to walk in; I missed the boot
camp, me and Method Man
>>David Oyelowo: Oh man!
>>Andre Royo: Thank God we were the mechanics
and we don’t gotta do all that boot camp.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: But as an actor, you know, goin'
onto the set and hanging out with the guys
when we got there, you know, it was unique
to see these guys all come together every
morning, they were like a family.
It wasn’t like people off, you know, you
go to other sets other actors are doing their
thing, they’re on Facebook, they’re not
really as together as these guys were every
morning at the hotel, eating together, working
out together, going for a run.
I took notice of that; I joined in on the
run, me and Method Man, joined in on the run.
>>Elijah Kelley: You joined in on the run,
Method Man
>>Andre Royo: Well, you know.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: He joined in, thought about
it, made a rhyme about it.
It was special.
[Laughter]
>>Rick McCallum: When he forgot his lighter
for his cigarettes.
>>Elijah Kelley: Ah, that’s messed up.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: But it was cool to see these
guys, it was cool, it was cool to see these
guys connected like that.
You could feel the bond was there.
And they did other things like take us up
on the B51s.
>>Elijah Kelley: Yeah!
>>Andre Royo: We all went up on that and that
was, you know, horrific and scary.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: So we definitely had experiences
that put us into the moment that you don’t
really get in films.
[Laughter]
>>Paul Snow: Excellent.
Thanks.
So we actually have a few youth groups with
us today from More Fire Nation.
>>Elijah Kelley: More Fire Nation.
Yeah.
>>Paul Snow: There we go.
And we’ve got Tomorrow’s Aeronautical
Museum here as well.
>>Elijah Kelley: Aeronauticals.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: I am so sorry.
>>Andre Royo: We’ve come so far.
We’ve come so far.
And now we go backwards.
[Laughter]
>>Paul Snow: So these youths, if somebody
asked them in a year when did they hear about
Tuskegee Airmen, they’ll have a very different
answer than what you did at the beginning
of this conversation.
>>Elijah Kelley: That’s what it’s about.
I think essentially there are minorities in
the United States.
Us as a culture right now, I feel like my
generation is fixated on fame.
Fame without works, meaning it happens overnight.
The opportunities that we’re granted, the
opportunities that Andre, David, myself, even
Rick, we fought for everything that we’ve
got.
And for minorities, my feeling, my vision
for these kids are to understand that these
are the shoulders that you stand on.
Michael Jordan, he’s amazing.
Tiger Woods is amazing, LeBron James is amazing.
These guys are phenomenal.
But to actually see these men, to see these
modern day super heroes, I always like to
say the only thing that separated them from
being Superman or Batman or Spiderman was
their mortality.
They went out, they fought, they saved the
world, it’s just as simple as that.
And for them see that, for them to see someone
that looks like them do that, you can’t
buy that type of inspiration, that’s life
long inspiration.
That’s something that no one can really
verbally instill in you, that’s something
that you have to see.
And I think that with this movie they were
able to see that.
And from what I’ve seen across the country,
and hopefully will continue to see around
the world, is that kids of all colors will
get inspired to see that type of bravery.
>>Paul Snow: Excellent.
Well thanks.
Let me open it up, I know there’s questions
from the audience both from the young people
that are here as well as the rest of the audience.
There’s a microphone we’ll pass around
so if you have a question, raise your hand.
>>Rick McCallum: We’re not leaving this
room til 1 o’clock in the morning.
[Laughter]
>>Male #1: Uh, I can say that one of the things
I find encouraging is that although some of
the older generations haven’t heard the
story of the Tuskegee Airmen, I think, at
least, starting with my generation, I think
it’s something that’s starting to be taught
a lot more in schools.
I mean, I grew up in Tennessee, which is not
exactly the most forward thinking of places,
but even still I remember hearing about the
Tuskegee Airmen several times throughout middle
school and high school.
But I’m also curious to hear how you guys
think this will be received by the international
community, especially you David as a Brit,
because it is a, although a very American
story, it is also something that is very unique
to, uh, just on a human level, and a level
of world history.
>>David Oyelowo: Well, I think one of the
things that drew George to wanting to make
it is he recognized the universal truth in
terms of what these men did.
We all face obstacles, whether it’s bullying
at school, whether it’s being a woman, whether
it’s being black or any sort of minority.
Or just being alive on earth today you face
obstacles.
And the great thing about the story, from
a universal point of view, like I’ve said
before is that they didn’t dwell on the
negative.
They knew what they had, by way of talent,
they worked hard on it, and they went out
and did their best every single time.
And also the universal truth, there’s a
beautiful biblical quote which is, “Greater
love hath no man than to lay his life down
for his friend.”
And that, to me, is the definition of love,
you know, to be prepared to lay down your
life for another person, for your country,
for your family.
If we all had that, to some degree, within
us, you know, I am absolutely certain the
world would be a better place.
And that’s why so often the war years are
called the “Great Generation” or “The
Finest Generation” because that was a time
where just because of the circumstances, these
people had to put their lives on the line
for truth, for justice and for their countries,
for the things that really mean so much.
And what Elijah is alluding to, in terms of
the generation that we live in now, is that
those kinds of pressures are certainly not
put on Western youth, you know, they’re
not.
We are free to be obsessed with ourselves,
with our technology, with what we look like
and with the idea of fame, because there isn’t
that pressure placed upon us to, you know,
look out for our fellow man.
So that is, I think, the universal truth within
Red Tails that I hope that anyone alive today
would see, regardless of whether you’re
American or black or other race.
>>Male #2: Okay, I have one question.
Was it fun when you were a pretty boy?
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: [Inaudible]
>>David Oyelowo: That’s a great question.
You know what, the,
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: Honestly, this is one of
the great things about being an actor is that,
you know, as you guys know, as those of you
here that are kids, going around your house
going
[Gun sounds]
>>David Oyelowo: You know you do that anyway.
No one has to be paying you to do that.
We literally got paid.
Literally.
>>Elijah Kelley: I didn’t do that.
>>David Oyelowo: He cried and did
[Gun noises]
>>Elijah Kelley: Why you keep telling people
I cried?
>>David Oyelowo: Because you gotta tell the
people the truth.
>>Elijah Kelley: Listen man.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: The truth will set you free.
>>Elijah Kelley: It will, but, let us just.
>>David Oyelowo: it’s okay, they’ll still
think you’re cool.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: But literally because we
had to
>>Rick McCallum: [Inaudible]
>>David Oyelowo: Because we obviously weren’t
up there flying, we were in a Gimbal, so it’s
a section of the plane that’s on poles that’s
being manipulated by these guys.
Because we had to learn each battle, so you
had to learn which plane was going where,
where you were looking at any given time,
which was really mind numbing by the way.
But it was so much fun, because literally
we were in there and someone off camera was
going, “B boys comin' at ya!”
[Gun Noises]
>>David Oyelowo: “Boom!
Boom!
Boom!”
[Gun noises]
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: “Look to your left, look
to your left!”
[Gun noises]
>>David Oyelowo: So every time you see me
go, “Whoa!” like that, it’s because
Nate Parker, is literally sat down there going,
“Look to your right!”
“Whoa!”
“Here he comes again!”
[Gun noises]
>>David Oyelowo: So the answer to your question
is it was great fun.
Pretty Boy wasn’t actually there, but visualizing
him and getting to shoot at him and getting
to do the trick where I do the flip and all
that.
I mean really I couldn’t believe that I
was going home to a paycheck after a day like
that.
So yeah, it was very fun.
>>Male #3: When Deacon was going down on his
plane, what would go through your mind if
you knew you was gonna die, or you’d be
in really bad condition if you survived?
>>Elijah Kelley: Oh wow.
That’s a
>>Rick McCallum: Very heavy duty.
>>Elijah Kelley: That is heavy duty.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: These kids is real smart.
>>Elijah Kelley: It is heavy duty.
Well, the first thing that you do, obviously,
is
>>Andre Royo: Wet yourself.
That’s what I’d do.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: Um,
>>Rick McCallum: Gather some fuel.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: I don’t know, for me, that,
a lot of things flashes in real life.
I feel like a character like Deke, with his
spirituality, he would probably think about
what he’s left on earth.
What kind of example he’s left for the people
around him, the family that he’s leaving.
Um, for me personally, I would just want to
be fulfilled in everything that God had called
me to do.
Death is, I can be very candid, it’s not
something I look forward to.
I’m terrified, just of the fact of losing
life, nobody knows what that entails.
I think that what is inspired by the possibilities
of that is to be as great as you can while
you have life.
So that transition is as easy as it can be
knowing that you’ve done everything that
you could for everybody that you can while
you’re here on earth.
[Applause]
>>Male #4: I just wanted to take a quick moment
at this moment it’s a great moment that
was an awesome word.
Thank you guys so much for making this film.
All my kids are so grateful, uh, I’m speaking
on behalf of More Fire Nation, they’re all
just really glad that y'all didn’t actually
die.
[Laughter]
>>Male #4: You guys are really alive.
So, they were asking on the way here, “Did
they really die?”
“No they didn’t, they’re gonna,”
[Laughter]
[Applause]
>>Male #4: Red team go!
[Laughter]
>>Male #5: Before they crashed, like a second
before it hit the ground, how did the pilot
get out and survive?
>>Male #6: I think what he’s saying is that
the special effects
>>Andre Royo: Look so real.
>>Male #6: look so real that they are convinced
that those airplanes
>>Andre Royo: Really crashed?
Yeah.
>>Male #6: Like, if those airplanes actually
crashed
>>Andre Royo: How’d he get the heck outta
there?
How’d he get outta there?
>>David Oyelowo: Oh!
>>Rick McCallum: There were many times when
I wanted the plane to crash.
[Laughter]
>>Rick McCallum: They were only 4 feet off
the ground so that was really hard.
>>David Oyelowo: I only have like 60 degree
burns, I mean I’m still
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: I’m still suffering man.
>>David Oyelowo: It’s hard out there for
a pilot.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: Well, that means we did our
job well that you think that we were actually,
I was never anywhere near an explosion.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: That’s where the joy of
all the
[Gun noises]
>>David Oyelowo: That’s where it would have
ended.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: Blow that up!
>>David Oyelowo: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>>Andre Royo: Eatin' Twizzlers.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: That was all make believe.
One of the great things about doing this film
with Rick and George and Lucas Films is that
they also own a company called ILM, Industrial
Light and Magic, who are some of the best
in the world at computer generated imagery.
So that make that stuff look so real, that
when I watched the movie I was like, the first
time I watched the movie, I’m gonna admit
this now, I got choked up about my own death.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: That’s how real, I’m
serious.
>>Andre Royo: I did good!
I did good!
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: I was sittin' behind him.
And he was like, “Elijah, didn’t I die
really well?”
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: “it was a great death”
>>David Oyelowo: Beautiful!
No, I’m serious, I had like a lump in my
throat, I was like, and that’s a testament
to the great work that you guys do.
>>Rick McCallum: The first time I sent you
the trailer, remember?
>>David Oyelowo: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I watched it with my kids.
Can you imagine, I have 3 sons, I have a 10-
year- old, a 7- year –old and a 3- year-
old, and can you understand how much of a
hero I am in my house?
When I show them that trailer, “That’s
my Dad!”
The best, the best.
I don’t think we answered your question
but it was fun anyway.
[Laughter]
>>Male #7: After realizing what the Tuskegee
airmen meant and what they did, as you being
asked to play a character of the Tuskegee
airmen, how did that feel for you?
>>Elijah Kelley: Well, now you have to keep
in mind that these guys, we got to meet these
men, these amazing men, who are as sharp,
as smart and as tactful as they are now as
they were then.
So you’re coming up to them every day and
literally Roscoe Brown would come up to you
and look at you, “We didn’t wear our jackets
like this.
There you go!”
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: And they have the like strongest
grandfather hands that just grip you in ways
that you just don’t understand.
And they’re like 89-90 years old.
So the greatest thing about it is you’re
getting firsthand information of how to portray
them.
The most frightening thing is if you don’t
do it right, those grapple hooks will come
out of nowhere and just grab you and tell
you what you’re doing right and what you’re
doing wrong.
They have this incredible quote, I don’t
wanna misquote it.
It begins with, “Excellence,” Roscoe Brown
always says that, “Excellence is the only
answer to,” Uh, what is it?
To ignorance or?
>>Rick McCallum: Ignorance and mediocrity.
>>Elijah Kelley: Yes, “Excellence is the
only answer to ignorance and mediocrity.”
So that was the format and the equation that
they preached to us all the time.
“Just be excellent, you’re doing great.
Just be excellent.
Just be excellent through adversity to the
stars.”
That’s how we got to the point to deliver
a film like Red Tails like we did.
And, more than anything it was just an honor
for them to be able to teach us.
We had an incredible director in Anthony Hemingway,
the creative side with Rick and George, as
well.
But to know that these heroes that you’re
portraying are right behind camera, rooting
for you, you know, the feeling was unparalleled.
>>Andre Royo: Yeah it was a great responsibility
and pride.
My remembrance of being at the ranch with
a couple of the Tuskegee airmen and we were
asking the questions on, “What’d you do
here?”
“What’d you think about this?” and one
of the cats asked them, “How’d you say
hi to somebody?
Did you give them dap?
Did you give them a hand?
Did you bump their shoulders?”
And this dude was like, “No, we walked up,
we shook their hand and we moved on.”
“So what?”
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: And it was just like, everybody
started sitting up like, “Oh shit!”
“For real, my fault, my fault.”
And you know, like Elijah said, they were
so proud of their story being told it made
us feel so proud that we were allowed to tell
their story.
And the two together, it was just you know,
memorable.
It was a fantastic experience.
>>David Oyelowo: But we also learned that
they’re show offs as well.
>>Andre Royo: Well, they got the right.
They got the right to.
>>David Oyelowo: I did so many interviews
with Roscoe where, especially if there’s
a pretty young lady, he’ll go, “You know
when there was lightening that blows up the
train?
That was me.
I did that.
Get the record straight.”
[Laughter]
>>Rick McCallum: [Inaudible]
>>David Oyelowo: Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
“I flew so low I bent my wing.”
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: I was like, “Real—yeah.”
>>Andre Royo: He waited a long time to say
it.
He waited like years.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: Yeah.
>>Elijah Kelley: You guys think this is a
spectacle to see them right now?
>>David Oyelowo: Oh my goodness.
>>Elijah Kelley: It’s like you’re a 91-year-old
telling an 89-year-old to shut up because
they’re too young to talk.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: it’s like that type of
stuff.
>>David Oyelowo: Literally.
>>Elijah Kelley: You know, it’s like people
telling lies about who dated Lena Horne.
It’s like that’s the types of things that
go on.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: “I danced with her all
night!”
“No you didn’t!”
>>Elijah Kelley: “Shut up!
You didn’t dance with Lena Horne.”
>>David Oyelow: “No you didn’t.
You didn’t dance with Lena Horne.
How come I danced with her?”
“Okay.”
[Laughter]
>>Paul Snow: So we probably have time for
one or two more questions.
>>Rick McCallum: Well, we’re cool.
>>Paul Snow: Great.
>>Male #8: How did you feel when you had to
fix the P51 D Mustang?
>>Andre Royo: I felt incompetent.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: I felt like I didn’t know
what I was doing.
Again, they gave us a lot of research.
We were at an air museum.
>>Elijah Kelley: Plane and Fame.
>>Andre Royo: Plane and Fame and I dealt with
some mechanics, they walked me around, they
taught me, gave me big, big books on how to
do it.
And there was no way in hell I could learn
that quick before we shot.
But, you know, it wasn’t really about the
plane as much as it was about somebody else’s
life.
If I don’t do this plane right it might
cost my fellow man his death.
So it was very personal to really go through
that plane and be very precise on every part
of the plane to make sure it worked well for
the pilot.
>>David Oyelowo: Which is why I died, cause
he didn’t know.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: [Inaudible]
>>David Oyelowo: Oh man.
>>Female #1: How did it feel to be a Tuskegee
Airmen?
Did it feel like you were a kid again playing
make believe?
>>David Oyelowo: Well like Elijah said, they
were heroes.
They flew, saved the world.
They were young and it was just, it was a
once in a lifetime opportunity, one that we’ll
take to our graves.
I mean, one of the highlights for us was we
got to take the film to the Whitehouse and
we got to screen it for the president.
>>Elijah Kelley: And the first lady.
>>David Oyelowo: And the first lady.
And what was so incredible, was we had a tour
of the Whitehouse before we showed it to them
and you know the Whitehouse with all that
history and with all these fusty white men
and their wigs and things like that through
the years.
>>Elijah Kelley: Rick and George.
>>David Oyelowo: Old and Balding.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: I cannot believe you just
said that.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: The movie is over.
We got paid.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: We got paid.
We got a movie.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: But it was just so incredible
to be in that building with all that history,
both negative and positive, and then to be
standing in a room waiting for the president,
and for this cool guy to come in and go,
[Clap]
>>David Oyelowo: “How y'all doin’?”
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: And you’re like, “Is
that the president?”
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: And he walked in and Michelle
Obama's giving hugs and the real Tuskegee
Airmen were there.
And you know, everywhere you looked there
were black faces.
You could almost see those paintings going.
>>Andre Royo: Melting.
“I’m melting!
I’m melting!
What are they doing?”
>>Rick McCallum: Especially the Kennedy ones
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: That’s right.
>>Andre Royo: I didn’t mean that far.
I didn’t mean that far.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: So, you know, to get to do
the movie and then to get to see the
>>Rick McCallum: And they served us popcorn.
>>David Oyelowo: And the little cookies, little
plane cookies in the Whitehouse.
>>Andre Royo: And M and Ms. Remember the M
and Ms?
>>David Oyelowo: Yeah!
It was incredible.
So the combination of getting to play those
men, getting to see them honored at the Whitehouse,
being there while they’re, having this movie
come out while there is an African American
president, it’s just like stuff you’ll
tell your grandkids, you’ll take to your
grave, it was just the most incredible experience.
>>Elijah Kelley: Yo!
All my little brothers, this is not only a
movie, this is a movement.
This is something we want you guys to take
and cherish for the rest of your lives.
You’re a part of this as well as us.
We did this for and with you guys.
Every day that we did this film we had people
like you in mind.
And I never would have known that we would
have got to take the film to the Whitehouse.
>>David Oyelowo: One of the best things that
has happened to me during the course of this
experience is the guy who literally put this
bandage on me, you know from the ankle abrasion
that I just had, said that he took his dad
to see Red Tails and it was the first time
his dad had been to the movie theater since
he saw Gandhi, thirty years ago.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: He’s got good taste.
>>David Oyelowo: Yeah, “If I’m gonna see
a movie, it’s gonna be a good movie!”
>>Andre Royo: “A movie like Gandhi!”
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: So, you know, I mean that
was like in the early '80s, so that bears
out what you’re saying
>>Andre Royo: Yes.
>>David Oyelowo: This is truly something that
people feel an ownership of in a different
way, you know, which is great.
>>Elijah Kelley: It creates a very honest
dialogue that can evolve into so many other
things, and that’s great.
You know, how many times have we heard people
say that men don’t know how to communicate?
So for a 10-year-old kid talking to his 60-year-old
grandfather and they meet somewhere in the
middle and get to share amazing stories that,
you know, these stories of triumph are timeless.
Where like you said, whether you’re dealing
with bullying or that father who was dealing
with some kind of racial injustice, these
stories coincide with each other.
And yeah, I never thought about that.
It does bridge that gap.
>>David Oyelowo: And how often do you go to
the movie theater and see someone so dark
and sexy?
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: You know it.
Preach it.
>>David Oyelowo: Like Elijah Kelley in a plane.
>>Elijah Kelley: Pause, but preach it!
[Laughter]
>>Male #9: When you first heard Ne-Yo’s
voice when he was acting did you laugh?
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: Cut the camera!
Cut the Camera!
Wow, this one, he’s on fire!
No.
>>David Oyelowo: Rick, over to you.
>>Rick McCallum: Absolutely not.
I still don’t understand a single word he
said in the film but I never laughed.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: There is the 5 P’s.
Prior preparation prevents poor performance.
And when you are, we say it a lot in our generation,
when you’re on your grind, when you’re
knowing everything that you’re supposed
to know, when you have everything that’s
intact, the minute somebody questions you
about what you know, there’s an immediate
rebuttal in the right way.
And whatever notion that was had about you
before then is canceled and there’s a new
beginning right there because you are so intelligence
and you’re so mentally able to talk intelligently
and articularly, articulate about everything
that you’ve consumed, all the knowledge
that you’ve had, the bank of hard drive
that you’ve been acquiring over the years.
You’re on and you’re ready.
And that’s another thing that, you know,
the Tuskegee Airmen stood for, that was something
that resonated all the way from just the mood
of who they were to coming on set and knowing
exactly what to do while we were there.
And again that’s prior preparation prevents
poor performance.
>>Female #2: Was it hard for you to change
your voice in the movie to make it sound straight
English?
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: Make your voice sound right
and regular, David!
It’s strange right?
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: What are you trying to say?
>>Female #2: To talk like that in the movie.
>>David Oyelowo: Oh, okay.
Well, that’s a compliment, I’ll take that.
>>Elijah Kelley: You know he thinks he’s
smarter than everybody because he talks like
that.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: This is Elijah’s inferiority
complex.
>>Elijah Kelley: See!
>>David Oyelowo: Every time I talk to him,
“I know what you’re doin’ David, you
think you’re so smart!”
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: Let me tell you, David, in
my opinion is one of the most incredible actors
of our generation.
It’s a testament to your, compliment, he
goes in so hard and he devotes himself at
a very, very, very, very interesting and accurate
pace that I haven’t seen from a lot of people.
And it’s something that a lot of people
on set learned from me, personally, and he’s
one of brightest stars in my eyes, performing
on screen.
I know that you guys lit up every time that
you saw Lightening and the strength that he
brought to the movie.
And he’s an amazing performer; you’ll
see so much more of him.
[Applause]
>>Elijah Kelley: I need 10 percent from the
rest of your movies.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: Yeah, I’ll tell ya later.
Yeah.
>>Elijah Kelley: 10 percent.
[Laughter]
>>David Oyelowo: I’ll hit you back.
>>Paul Snow: Alright.
Andre, David, Eli, Rick.
>>Elijah Kelley: Elijah!
You called me Eli man!
[Laughter]
>>Paul Snow: I’m sorry.
>>Andre Royo: Chill out.
Chill out.
>>Elijah Kelley: It’s black history month.
>>Rick McCallum: That is so white.
[Laughter]
>>Elijah Kelley: Tuskegee Airmen, and he’s
gonna mess up my name on live internet.
[Laughter]
>>Andre Royo: He didn’t call you Negro.
At least he didn’t call you Negro.
[Laughter]
>>Rick McCallum: Kelley Kelley, it’s first.
>>Paul Snow: Well congratulations on an amazing
movie.
>>Elijah Kelley: Thank you.
>>David Oyelowo: Thank you.
>>Paul Snow: Really appreciate you spending
the time with us here.
>>Andre Royo: Thank you guys.
>>All: Thank you.
[Applause]